hello
in a last video on cryptography we took
a look at symmetric key cryptography
we used a single private key for both
the encryption and decryption of data
and it works very well in theory let's
take a look at a more realistic scenario
now
let's meet joe joe is a journalist who
needs to communicate with ryan via long
distance messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now joe can easily use symmetric
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says
but here's the tricky part how will joe
send the required decryption key to ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key
so that they can exchange messages
otherwise ryan cannot decrypt the
information
even when he receives the cipher text if
someone intercepts the key while
transmitting it
there is no use in employing
cryptography since a third party can now
decode all the information easily
key sharing is a risk that will always
exist when symmetric key cryptography is
being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
this is bever from simply learn and
welcome to this video on asymmetric key
cryptography
let's take a look at what we are going
to learn today we begin by explaining
what
asymmetry key cryptography is and how it
works
we take a look at its application and
uses we understand why it's called
public key cryptography and then learn a
little bit about rs encryption
and then we learn about the advantages
of asymmetric key cryptography
over symmetric key cryptography
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
a public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit
and a private key is used to decrypt the
data post transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared via
messaging blog posts or key servers
and there are no restrictions as you can
see in the image
the two keys are working in the system
the sender first encrypts the message
using the receiver's private key
after which we receive the cipher text
the cipher text is then transmitted to
the receiver without any other key
on getting the cipher text the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt it and
get the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message
and the private key which can decrypt
the message need not be shared with
anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible to understand this
better
take the analogy of your mailbox anyone
who wants to send you a letter has
access to the box
and can easily share information with
you in a way
you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key
that can open the mailbox and read the
letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play no one can intercept the message
and read its contents since it's
encrypted once the receiver gets
its contents he can use his private key
to decrypt the information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if alice wants to
send a message to bob
let's say it reads call me today she
must use bob's public key while
encrypting the message
upon receiving the cipher message bob
can proceed to use his private key in
order to decrypt the message
and hence complete securities attained
during transmission
without any need for sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many uses in areas that
require high confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon
thanks to asymmetric cryptography
senders can now sign documents with
their private keys
anyone who needs to verify the
authenticity of such signatures
can use the sender's public key to
decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards
but the background implementation
follows the similar approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetry key
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions
and maintain the system thanks to its
two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer network
only if it is approved from both ends
along with asymmetric key cryptography's
tamper-proof architecture
its non-repudiation characteristic also
helps in keeping the network stable
we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetrical
cryptography
to monitor ssl or tls encrypted
browsering sessions
to make sure nobody can steal our
personal information when accessing
banking websites or the internet in
general
it plays a significant role in verifying
websites of authenticity
exchanging the necessary encryption keys
required and generating a session using
those keys
to ensure maximum security instead of
the rather insecure http website format
security parameters differ on a session
by session basis
so the verification process is
consistent and utterly essential to
modern data security
another great use of the asymmetric key
cryptography structure
is transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography
with the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the cipher text
using the receiver's public key
now we have two cipher text to transmit
to the receiver on receiving both of
them the receiver uses his private key
to decrypt the symmetry key
he can then use it to decrypt the
original information on getting the key
used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetry key cryptography
alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography
let us understand why asymmetric falls
under the public key cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal the
encryption key is available to everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system
to put that into perspective we share
our email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us
it is supposed to be public by design so
that our email login credentials are
private
and they help in preventing any data
mishandling
since there is nothing hidden from the
world if they want to send us any
encrypted information
this category is called the public key
cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetric
cryptography none more famous than the
rs encryption
rsa encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetric
approach named after its founders rivest
shamir and edelman it uses block ciphers
to obscure the information
if you are unfamiliar with how block
ciphers work there are encryption
algorithms that divide the original data
into blocks of equal size
the block size depends on the exact
cipher being used
once they are broken down these blocks
are encrypted individually
and later chained together to form the
final cipher text
widely considered to be the most secure
form of encryption
albeit relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms
it is widely used in web browsing secure
identification
vpns emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrically cryptography an edge
over the traditional symmetric
encryption methodologies
let's go through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recruit any confidential information
and the only key that can decrypt
doesn't need to be shared publicly
under any circumstance we have much more
extensive key lengths in rsa encryption
and other asymmetric algorithms like
2048 bits key and 4096 bit keys
larger keys are much harder to break
into via brute force
and are much more secure asymmetric key
cryptography can use as a proof of
authenticity
since only the rightful owner of the
keys can generate the messages to be
decrypted by the private key
the situation can also be reversed
encryption is done
using a private key and decryption is
done by the public key
which would not function if the correct
private key is not used to generate the
message
hence proving the authenticity of the
owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot
be intercepted and changed without
invalidating the private key used to
encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate
when and where the case requires
hope you learned something interesting
today feel free to ask us in the
comments section if you have any more
questions
and subscribe to our channel for videos
like this thanks for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here